says it will stop taking part in
consultations over the downing of
malaysian airlines flight
17. the tragedy took place over eastern
ukraine in july
2014. six years later the investigation
is still ongoing
our correspondent maria fanoshna earlier
joined me in the studio and gave us
all the details it is explained in a
document the last row for russia was the
government of the netherlands filing a
lawsuit against
russia in the european court for human
rights alleging moscow had played a role
in
the mh-17 passenger airplane crash back
in 2014
russia denies all the allegations
accusing the netherlands
of being interested in only putting all
the blame on russia
rather than fighting the truth here's
the russia's foreign ministry
the dutch move is considered yet another
blow to russian dutch relations and the
hague court's determination
contrary to common sense is to continue
on the wrong path of unilateral
attribution of responsibility to russia
for what happened in the sky above
donbass
such unfriendly acts by the netherlands
make it senseless for us to continue
to participate in the three-way
consultations responsibility
for the breakdown of the consultations
thus lies entirely with the hague
we already received the netherlands
reaction they say they deeply
uh regret that russia took the decision
but
by the way in the same announcement of
russia's foreign ministry it is
explained that
they only are right now out of this
consultation team
that they will continue cooperating with
the netherlands services
involved in the investigation six years
has passed
what do we know about the tragedy well i
remember that day july 17
2014 three months after kyiv launched
what it's called a massive
count terror operation in eastern
ukraine using aviation heavy artillery
tanks i was there on the ground since
day one and i remember how quickly
turned into a very bloody deadly
operation
the situation on the ground was boiling
it was really dramatic the
real war in fact was raging when this
uh tragedy happened above eastern
ukraine
the investigation has been going on ever
since
until today we did not know exactly what
had happened
these are the key points
[Music]
so kiev and anti-government forces were
very quick to accuse each other and
interesting is that
in that situation the netherlands backed
the position
of official kiev and according to uh the
dutch sled joint investigation team the
plane was brought down by book
surface to a missile fired from the
rebel control
territory but interesting is that no
satellite
radar data supported this uh actually
version the thing is that russia
has been complaining repeatedly that the
netherlands
do not accept russia's documents and
russia's materials he is
russia's president vladimir putin
talking about it whatever they presented
doesn't say anything we have our own
theory
we have presented it but no one wants to
listen to us and unless there is
uh dialogue we will not find the right
response to the questions that still
remain unanswered
related to the tragedy of mh17 related
to the deaths of people
and we mourn these deaths and we believe
that
these such incidents are unacceptable so
as you understand what we're here today
from russia's foreign ministry it didn't
start yesterday all this lack of trust
this
misunderstanding has been piling for
months and years
moscow's had long time reservations
about it does anyone else in the
international community
share this questioning the investigation
malaysia is on russia's side also
as you know it was malaysia airlines
airplane
and here is the country's prime minister
talking about this investigation and
also calling it
politicized from the very beginning we
see too much politics in it
the idea was not to find out
how this happened and all that but they
seem to be concentrated on trying to pin
it on russia had it been a neutral party
examining and making conclusions we are
always willing to accept but here we
have parties who have some
political interests in the matter what
is important
now is that yes russia is out of
three-way consultations but moscow says
it is open and ready to cooperate with
the netherlands services and other
countries services
anybody involved in the investigation
and anybody interested in finding the
truth
you